people who wouldn't agree on what day of
the week this is agreed that the
Department of Justice was becoming
almost a terrorist organization with
respect to state local and even federal
public officials that's what causes
change the people in power begin to get
hurt by their own system I am Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Harvey silverglade he's the
co-author of the shadow University you
read a great book called three felonies
a day he's a co-founder of the
foundation for individual rights and
education and a great civil libertarian
Harvey thanks for talking to us it's my
pleasure this is gonna be interesting
you have written a lot about over
criminalization in American life what is
over criminalization and you know what
are the egregious forms that it takes
there are two allied concepts
there's over criminalization too many
things have been made into crimes but
then there is a kind of a vicious
relative and that is statutes that are
so vague that no normal human being can
figure out what it is so what what's an
example of over something that's been
criminalized that shouldn't be and then
what's an example of a statute that is
so vague it can mean anything there's
this enormous number of statutes from
regulations in the country federally
there are hundreds of thousands of
hundreds of thousands of regulations
under each of the federal criminal
statutes so if there are about 30,000
statutes there are at least ten times
that many regulations and Counting every
day regulations are added these
regulations which nobody can assume it's
not a matter of common sense you can't
assume that you know you
you know walking in certain areas of a
federally protected forest is a crime
it's not even posted you just assumed to
know it and you can be picked up and you
can be charged and these are real
criminal violations what are the three
felonies a day yesterday that you you
committed there's this federal statute
wire fraud okay that means if you use
the wires of interstate communication in
order to further a crime or a fraud you
have committed a federal offense okay so
your up your sales men let's say you're
on the telephone with a somebody you're
trying to sell a computer system or
anything and you you're puffing a little
bit right you are
you're arguably slightly exaggerating
the robustness of the system you know
the kind of thing
car salesmen are most famous for this
but any kind of salesman and you're you
you're if that conversation was recorded
a prosecutor can pick out something
which arguably can say you use the wires
of Interstate Commerce the phone in
order to perpetuate a fraud you told a
lie with a goal of selling somebody
something that wasn't quite as good as
you made it out to be you've committed a
felony are people actually being
prosecuted on that or is this kind of
like a sword of Damocles that is hanging
over our head so that it's just a
pretext and if we don't even know we're
breaking the law does the law actually
govern up govern our action well yes
people are being prosecuted one of the
reasons people are being prosecuted is
we have too many people working for the
government and not enough useful work
for them to do so you do have this
phenomenon of government people looking
for somebody who's committing a crime so
if you know you're a Bobby unser you're
you you've got a you're taking a sled
ride
a power sled ride and there's a storm
and you you accidentally go into an area
in federally protected land where you're
not allowed to have the snowmobiles he
he got charged in that case it was
completely accidental that he got into
that area because of a storm
well he's prosecuted and these are the
kinds of crimes for which a good intent
is not a defense there's no what we call
mens rea requirement you don't have to
know that it was a crime to go over this
invisible line now you know mens rea
comes up a lot because we are talking
about sentencing reform we're talking
about you know changing a lot of this
and that people's justice reform adding
that israel require and is that a good
thing or a bad thing because it seems a
you know critics say oh that will let
among other things that'll let corporate
malefactors off the hook the critics the
cynicism of the critics of mens rea
reform you can't there's no way of
overestimating the cynicism of these
people they're saying it would be a
terrible thing because the people we
don't like corporate executives is they
will be able to get off by arguing that
there's absolutely no criminal intent on
their part that you know so you want
absolute criminal liability for people
you don't like however when they come in
for you
suddenly you say well you know I didn't
intend to break the law they want a
separate set of laws essentially for the
people they don't like a separate set
for themselves their allies and they're
protected to protect these why isn't
there a mens rea component already in
place that is robust enough to will
arrest them first of all a lot of people
don't realize this federal criminal law
is not related to common law so state
systems have large common law elements
Renne raya is a common law protection in
order to convict somebody you have to
show they meant to commit the act and
they knew that committing the act
violated the law those two elements are
necessary in
common law courts mostly state courts
the federal system that's not true
federal station op the system operates
by statute and if you want to have a
mens rea requirement the statute has to
provide it an enormous number of federal
statutes do not provide and by the way
that's probably accidental you know
legislators don't always know what
they're doing and then there were these
hundreds of thousands of regulations
each one of which has the the power and
effect of being a separate criminal law
and they are made up by bureaucrats so
there's the number of missteps you can
make in the course of a day just in the
federal system is frightening and
enormous how did we get here what are
the political the cultural the legal
mindsets that and actions that brought
us to a world in which we're always
already guilty it wasn't by design was
it by accident is it a combination of
the two I think that it is largely
accidental it kind of grew like Topsy
part of it was the vast increase in the
last several decades of the bureaucrats
and bureaucrats think about bureaucrats
is that they need something to do
because we have way too many federal
employees way too many state bureaucrats
as well and when you have although we
have fewer federal employees per capita
than we did in the Kennedy
administration well that doesn't mean
that the Kennedy administration was the
same time it hasn't been saying the 20th
century was not the same time the
federal government so weirdly in
American life and I know somebody who
came of age in the 60s you know that the
fight was always against the bureaucrats
whether they were in big business at GM
or at the Pentagon or on college
campuses where who is I mean are the
bureaucrats self multiplying or like
nobody
buycks bureaucrats right so why why do
we keep getting more of them well they
are self multiplying in the sense that
they're constantly telling the system
whoever is doing the hiring or
allocating the funds that they need more
people in order to perform the function
on the other hand they partly establish
what the function is so we have an over
lured society and in order to in order
to carry out the task of enforcing these
laws you need an increasing number of
bureaucrats and you know in the colleges
it's gotten especially bad you've got
many many colleges that do not have the
money to hire faculty members who are on
tenure track so they hire adjuncts who
have paid very small amounts of money or
you can get somebody paid three thousand
dollars teachers semester course and you
so the students are not being taught by
seasoned experienced tenured or
tenure-track professors they're being
taught by part-time adjunct to during
the day you know part of that is the the
roses that is that so much of the money
is sucked up in order to support a ever
growing bureaucracy the student life
bureaucracy is just monumental are you
optimistic that we're going to be paring
back some of the over criminalization or
the mass statute ization of American
life I think that we are on the verge of
a massive reaction against overweening
federal power and I don't mean because
people have become libertarian so people
who become Federalists I think it's much
more unlock all of that guess what
people have become targets people who
become defendants everybody knows
somebody who was prosecuted for
something that either shouldn't have
been a crime or they didn't intend to do
anything criminal
and everybody knows somebody or
everybody has somebody in their family
and as more and more victims of an
out-of-control system
pile up they are starting to wake up
about that's why there's a movement now
to to effectuate mens rea reform you
know too many stories are now being told
in the newspapers about somebody who got
up in the morning didn't intend to
commit a crime did something and ended
up ended up with a prison sentence what
are the hinge points what are the key
things that have to happen to make sure
that you know this urge towards deep
bureaucratize in our lives and and deed
lawyer in our lives actually hits home
so many people now have been have been
hurt by the system and including and
this is critical members of Congress
members of state legislators governors
who have been indicted this is the they
just argued former Virginia Governor
McDonnell's case in the Supreme Court I
got before you this evening as someone
who has been falsely and wrongfully
accused and his public service has been
wrongfully attacked earlier today
federal prosecutors filed criminal
charges against me and my wife Maureen
alleging that we violated federal law by
accepting gifts and loans and the
lawyers for Virginia were obviously
quite taken aback they were getting
possible questions from all but one I
think they would toe in total shock why
is that the case they were a makai
briefs filed by an enormous number of
former attorneys general state attorneys
general a few federal attorneys general
former governors wool gang to get the
people who wouldn't agree on what day of
the week this is agreed and that the
Department of Justice was becoming
almost a terrorist organization with
respect to state local and even federal
public officials that's what causes
change that people in power begin to get
hurt by their own system let's talk
about free speech
yeah particularly on college campuses
you co-founded the foundation for
individual rights in education you also
co-authored the shadow University with
Alan Coors talk about when you started
fire how bad things were and then are
they better or worse in the intervening
years when I co-founded fire with Alan
course I assumed that fire would have
about a 10-year life we were not looking
to start an institution I thought that
it was needed in order to deal with a
temporary public panic and insanity you
know suddenly the mid-eighties speech
codes and academic campuses on campuses
that were liberal arts campuses speech
codes certain things you couldn't talk
about kangaroo courts to enforce the
speech codes I figured it was such
there's such dissonance that presented
by these institutions growing up on the
campuses that if we did a little push
back just a little push back this
edifice would collapse of its own its
own idiocy and inappropriateness
inappropriateness very important word
because you're talking here about
liberal arts colleges where free speech
and free ideas are supposed to be
paramount and so I figured ten years and
then we would go out of business a
little that I realized that things were
going to be getting worse during those
ten years talk about an early case you
know that helped push you to create fire
and then talk about how nowadays that
wouldn't you know it almost wouldn't
even register well I'll tell you what
got us the start fire was the
publication of the shadow university it
came out in 98 and suddenly Coors and I
were getting of phone calls and panic
letters from people on college campuses
who were in trouble for doing things
that no sane human being would think was
a violation of
oh saying something that injured the
feelings of a fellow student or an
administrator or a faculty member and of
demonstrating politically outside of a
free speech so we had thought whole
campus was a free speech zone not true
they would segregate that people who had
the audacity to want to you know voice
their sometimes unpopular views they
would put them in a little corner away
away from the center of the campus and
if they ventured outside of that little
corner they were charged with a form of
trespassing actually the free speech
zone is a small triangle on campus
there's really no regular foot traffic
when we measured the size of the free
speech zone it came out that it was only
0.1% of the entire land area of the main
campus here we had suddenly had all of
these phone calls and letters from
students who were being charged with
things which seem to be normal life on a
college campus and said we couldn't
handle it you know we there weren't
enough boys right handle it so we
started fire in order to process all
these and try to number one find help
for the students number two we undertook
the task of writing letters to the
presidents and to the deans to explain
why it is that this particular action
could not be a violation this action
couldn't be Rosen if you have a rule
against this it's the rule that's the
problem not the student that's a problem
and I figured you point out to an
administrator how absurd the
administrator is happening surely the
administrator will see the light of day
well no not how the administrator
reacted when we started to harangue them
as they hired more assistants to deal
with us so you're you're part of the
reason why college is so bureaucratize
and costs more money no they have their
own reasons for being bureaucratized but
I will admit that many campuses have a
couple of bureaucrats who are tasked
with dealing you know if
fire calls you know how to deal it how
to find right we knew that we were we
were arriving at respectability when
they started to teach how to deal with
it
universities there was this flourishing
in post-war colleges as college became
more mainstream and more mass you know
more people had started going there was
a move to get rid of in loco parentis
the idea that you would go to college
and the college would act in the place
of the parents and it was no college was
a place that you know and this started
in the late 60s came fully online in the
70s and then was ramped down or shut
down in the 80s but you know college was
a place where it was a free place on an
autonomous zone for the students and you
could direct your own lives you could
direct your own education that vanished
and then also you talked a lot about the
effects or the influence of Herbert
Marcus's concept of repressive tolerance
talk a little bit about why in the end
of in loco parentis was so seem to be so
brief and then also how mark who'sa is
still kind of guiding a lot of holidays
the the gradual almost disappearance of
in loco parentis had another aspect to
it that you didn't mention but that is
crucially important at that period of
time the college is opened up the
admissions process and you suddenly got
on campuses that were basically you know
took what for centuries or decades took
white anglo-saxon Protestants suddenly
there were people of different religions
and no religion there were people of
different races there were people
different genders the elite schools were
yep so the early seventies so suddenly
you had co-education and you sudden so
you suddenly had all of these different
students who are probably not living
together in the neighborhoods where they
grew up which were much more segregated
who was suddenly living together on the
same campus campus administrators made
an assumption fatal assumption that
without adequate supervision by adult
bureaucrats to dn't life bureaucrats
these students would kill each other
and so they immediately ramped up the
student life bureaucrats and you know
what bureaucrats love to do they write
rules and suddenly the campuses were
less free than they ever were and my own
view is that was the fatal mistake why
because students actually get along
fairly well if left alone and I've seen
it I've dealt with students my entire
legal career they do get along but when
you've got bureaucrats who operate on
the assumption that they're prepared to
kill each other and that sort of
permeates everybody's thinking on the
campus and suddenly you have all these
rules to keep students from assaulting
each other and from embarrassing each
other from talking and upsetting fashion
to each other this is on liberal arts
campuses we are supposed to talk in an
upsetting
fashions because you trying to say
things honestly rather than you're
always sugarcoating them right that's
the nature of these our liberal arts
institutions searching for the truth and
so you had this bureaucracy working
counter to the ethos of the liberal arts
institution and this started and they
started to adopt speech codes suddenly
on a college campus you couldn't say
something that upset somebody literally
this was written into a code and if you
said something upsetting the student can
complain about it and you were suddenly
charged what so that's how fire you know
we have a very big speak free speech um
a component of our work that's how it
started when you look at college
campuses now 17 years later why are they
worse what is driving it and then what
are the chances of pulling it back this
is the dark side of accepting federal
money if you're if you're running a
university the dark side is that ninety
nine point something percent of these
colleges are now dependent on these
infusions of federal funds and all the
office of civil rights has to do is say
if you don't hire three more bureaucrats
in the office of sexual assault
prevention we are going to find you
deficient in this in regard to dealing
with sexual assault and you're gonna
lose extra millions X tens of billions X
hundreds of millions of dollars in
federal funds even though I doubt
there's a college in the country that
couldn't win a lawsuit very quickly if
there was an attempt to take away their
funds they cave in instantly no guts
what changes positions in the Office of
Civil Rights is that the bureaucrats
there is at the president who appoints
the Secretary of Education the
bureaucracy has a life of its own
operates on a trajectory of its own it's
there's so many of them it's even hard
for the president to know what is who
and what is in the bureaucracy and what
they're doing at any given time and you
know occasionally there's a congressman
who you usually somebody who has a kid
in college and there's heard some horror
stories you have a congressman who asks
for a congressional investigation that's
how some of these things come to the
surface but essentially the bureaucracy
has a life of its own it's self
governing self perpetuating and in order
to get rid of it you have to kind of you
know the expression pull it out root
branch the the office should be
abolished I simply have to say I don't
it's not reformable it's got a culture
that is inimical to the whole concept of
higher education academic freedom due
process and fairness they don't
understand any of this much less have
any fidelity to it the office should be
abolished talk a bit about Mark ooza and
how his ideas are still at play even if
people inhabiting them are using them
don't quite understand well mark who'sa
in the 60s came up with what I would
call to use a John McCain ISM a wacko
theory according to Freud the more
intense the depression in a society the
more what happened is
a mobilization of surplus aggressiveness
against this repression the wacko Theory
put as simply as I can make it is that
in order to achieve true equality rights
have to be assigned differentially
people who are in the victim classes
lower socioeconomic classes certain
racial classes they in order for them to
achieve equality they have to have more
rights than the people who are at the
top of the totem pole in the pecking
order they have to have decreased rights
so this idea of equality is achieved by
having a differential assignment of
rights you would think it's a self you
know it's like it's a sick joke in a way
but it gained a lot of traction in
academic circles where else could
something as wacky as this for a second
because I mean isn't that like if you
say you're you know it's 1964 and you're
black and you're poor you might get more
money from the government in order to
level the fact you know that you haven't
had certain advantages I mean this is
affirmative action essentially
affirmative action has real problems
because it operates on an assumption of
the differential assignment of rights
that has real downside and how we could
avoid affirmative action you know
there's the process of of lowering
standards for certain students to get in
through college we can avoid that by
giving them a decent education in the
first place from kindergarten on instead
of dealing with that problem if the when
they've graduated kids who really can't
read very well who can't write very well
who don't come haven't read much history
they graduate these kids and they're
suddenly having to show one them into
colleges for which the kids who are ill
prepared and then with the markussi an
idea of assigning differential rights of
course that implies a bureaucracy or a
system that can I
if I you know the the inequality and
rectified somebody has got to establish
the categories for the under mention
right you want to be separate separate
the uber mention from the under mention
somebody is going to decide who's in
what category and those are the favorite
categories they're allowed you know
they're allowed heightened speech rights
for example so this is really quite mark
using a person who's in a privileged
category they can easily demean somebody
by what they say who's in a less
advantaged position but the person in a
less advantaged position can say what
they want because there's no way they're
going to be able to hurt the person and
they in the higher position the more
favorite position so you've got
differential assignment of rights it is
the enemy of legal equality and legal
equality is the only thing that protects
all of us we live in an age where reason
interviewed Edward Snowden a while ago
and you know we he was in an undisclosed
location in Russia and he said you know
the individual has more freedom and
ability to act in the world than ever
before
do you know and it's true I mean in
terms of free speech we are in orders of
magnitude faster we can say what we want
and reach audiences and connect and
preserve you know our thoughts and on
the other hand we're looking at places
where the Obama administration has been
terrible to journalists in particular
where the government is surveilling
everything that we say and do that
college campuses are like the
re-education camps
so are we you know is free speech moving
forward or backwards or you know how do
you feel about that Joe and I was a
young kid this may have been before you
a time I don't know Mad Magazine
we read every issue of Mad Magazine and
they came out and there was a there was
a there was a feature called spy versus
spy
there was a white clothes spy and the
black clothes spy no racial overtones a
would if you if you drew this cartoon
on a college campus you would be
disciplined of course because they would
read it as a racial comment but it
wasn't and I kind of see the world
through med magnum from several reasons
I see the world through the eyes of Mad
Magazine but one of them is that it's a
spy versus spy the forces of repression
and the government using the latest
electronic device mechanisms of their
fighting the the private citizens the
the techies the journalists the people
who want to find out the government
secrets and let that secret out so that
the people who vote after all know what
they're voting for and so this is a this
is attention who's gonna win
well my probably neither side is gonna
win and that's okay with me as long as
the dumpers you don't leave as long as
we don't lose that's ok with me what it
means is that the preservation of
Liberty is a constant struggle what's
new about that absolutely nothing but do
you worry and I know Greg luciana off
the the current executive director of
fire talks a lot about how in this
context both in terms of on college
campuses and more broadly and in society
that the very idea of free speech is
under it's not even that it's under
attack but that it's it's kind of
vanishing the problem the thing that is
coming I think Greg so upset what has me
upset is not that it's vanishing not
that it's under attack it's always been
under attack but it's under attack from
quarters that once we could count on as
allies and that is academic community of
the college community those those folks
are now largely the enemy we have to
fight them and while we're trying to
fight the government we're also trying
to fight the bureaucrats and the other
oppressors on the college campus you
know that you've been investigated by
the FBI
yeah at least three times talk about
those cases and how you
or instances and how you discovered that
in one case there was a client's were
being indicted for drug operation and
there was attempt by the prosecution the
US Attorney's Office here in Boston to
freeze and forfeit all of their assets
claiming they were drug tainted that's
done by the government in order to
disable them from being able to pay for
legal counsel that's really what the
government didn't need the money but
they didn't want these people to have
money for lawyers and so for private
lawyers and so we were trying to get
witnesses to sign affidavits and testify
that the money that these clients were
using came from a private real estate
business that they had rather than from
any kind of drug business so the strike
comes in he says oh yeah he said I've
dealt with your clients before and I can
testify that to some of the real estate
deals they did and they made money on
them and so forth so I was oh good well
we'll have you doing affidavit so he
dictates you affidavit have it typed up
bring it in and he's about to Sciences
by the way you know none of this is true
but I really like your clients so and
I'm gonna I'm gonna sign it and at that
point I smelled a rat I said wait wait
don't sign anything I walked around and
I saw he had a white kind of flowing
Muslim shirt on and sort of a Lawrence
of Arabia type shirt and I going back
and they see that there's a but there's
a there's a lump in his back a square
alum and I realized it's what they call
the Kell said it was their small what
was them many as you record they're now
much more miniaturized and I realized
that he had been sent in by the
government so I said no no you don't
know you don't understand the system or
our role on the system I gave him a
civics lecture talking to the recorder
naturally I said I'm afraid we're gonna
have to send you home we can't use your
affidavit but thanks for coming by and
we threw him out what are the other
if--and I found out years later somebody
had comic
it accidentally filed in another case
report that DEA agents were surveying my
office that was standing outside my
office following me around to see what I
do in it I was being investigated by
these thugs and they had gotten the
wrong guy shows you this is government
work right that somebody walked out of
my office building on Broad Street
Boston and they followed him thinking it
was me it wasn't me
they follow him down to what was then
the elevated expressway there was a car
parked under the elevated expressway the
guy gets in and has a sexual encounter
with a young lady who was behind the
steering wheel and they're all excited
they go over to the window they knocked
on the window the guy is horrified it
turns out of course he's got a wife and
kids at home right and they they said
you're Harvey silverglade aren't you and
what does the guy supposed to say oh no
no I'll show you my driver's license I'm
Joe Smith I married my wife lives in
Malden so the guy says oh yeah I'm
Harvey so goodnight so they're all
excited they've now caught me in
flagrante delicto so to speak and this
they made and only later did they
realize they had the wrong guy I wasn't
even around I was in town that day talk
a little bit about your kind of
intellectual genealogy or journey you
you know why it was civil libertarianism
something that you came out of the womb
believing in or what what brought you to
your set of beliefs I had a kind of
typical middle-class Jewish upbringing
and a half Jewish neighborhood in
Brooklyn and then my father who was a
furrier at the time was having trouble
with the fur Union they were sending
thugs around they didn't like the fact
that he reported a crooked election so
we moved to New Jersey where he was able
to get away from the furriers Union and
New Jersey suburbs suburb of Hackensack
I did not like the suburbs I was a
Brooklyn boy and I left from there and
went on to college and Princeton because
I had a big scholarship
Princeton was just beginning to open up
to two Jewish kids and with no money I
got a full scholarship and my parents
and my grandparents of course told me I
was gonna go to medical school and be a
nice Jewish doctor just like you know
that's what they came over from Russia
that's what they escaped from Russia and
Poland for so I could be a doctor right
that's a heavy burden and then the end
of my sophomore year for that summer for
the first time I left the territory of
the United States and I went to abroad
they got me a job Princeton got me a job
paid for my transportation that work in
Paris and it was my first time out of
the country I was away from family for
three blessed months that summer and I
rethought my entire life I came back
deciding that the things that people do
to each other much more bothersome to me
than the things the germs do to people
and I decided I was going to go into
journalism and I was gonna go to law
school so that I could understand the
legal system better sites when I started
out Law School with journalists the
career in mind ran into Alan Dershowitz
it was his first year at Harvard Law
School
my first year we became friends and by
the third year he convinced me I should
try to I would work take the bar exam
work in a legal office for a couple
years to see whether I wanted to
actually be a criminal lawyer or a crime
reporter and I went to both III got out
I got a job with a very interesting
little firm that did criminal defense
work I did some First Amendment work and
I decided that I would be a little bit
of both I would be a practitioner and I
would write about it and there were very
few legally trained people those days
who wrote that was one of the first
people I wrote for the Boston Phoenix a
you know a countercultural newspaper
there actually wrote that the
my criticism of judges lawyers it was
unheard of to criticize a judge in print
the assumption was that you would lose
your you know they wouldn't like you you
wouldn't do as well on cases quite the
opposite suddenly I got treated very
well I got treated fairly
they weren't friendly but I got treated
fairly because if they really did
terrible things I would write about it
you know and so fear is a tremendous
power and they don't like you know
sunlight is the best disinfectant it's
true who are your legal heroes
Alex Kaczynski in the Ninth Circuit
there's somebody who he doesn't care if
people like him or not he tells tells
the truth he writes legal opinions he
holds prosecutors feet to the fire you
know naturally I thought Clarence Darrow
was a somewhat of a role model Alan
Dershowitz was a great influence we did
a lot of cases together and for a while
I was ahead of him because I had more
experience but Luke was a brilliant
strategist and an appellate lawyer and
so woman I've had some law partners
who've had a lot of guts and that's
really the people who make the system
work though it's yeah the people who
make the system work are the people who
are not afraid to say you know the old
truth to power who aren't a lot who
aren't afraid to say when the judge or a
prosecutor or an FBI agent totally out
of hand just as an endpoint you are
writing a sequel to three felonies a day
what is the title and what do you hope
to accomplish with that book and when
will we see it on our shelf well three
felonies a day remember was a book that
talked about quirks in the system that
that easily easily could result in the
conviction of innocent people
I had represented enough people where
they had been convicted and sentenced to
long prison terms for not doing anything
that I would consider criminal just as
an ordinary reasonably Oakland
human
and it had a tremendous influence I was
actually surprised lawyers were getting
to touch with me defendants people who
were in prison who had cases that were
equally as outrageous as anything I
wrote about and then I was getting kind
of confidential communications from
judges that told me that the system was
really broken and even judges some
judges understood it a lot of them
dramatically played along and some of
them cynically played along
but everybody realized that the system
was broken and I even heard believe it
or not from a few federal prosecutors
the condition that I never mentioned
that they contacted me and I'm not about
to mention you know I was fired
next question band it couldn't be take
this left or right because I talked
about victims on all ends of the
political spectrum and you know
businessman and artists and and some
quite ordinary ordinary people and so
Roger Kimball was said to me about two
years ago you know Harvey everybody
tells me that your book is brilliant in
setting out the problem and totally
deficient because you don't suggest the
solutions and I said well when I wrote
read the wrote the book I wasn't sure
what the solutions were and besides you
told me I already had a manuscript that
was twice as long as it could be is it I
want you to write a follow-up to the
book that suggests solutions and I want
you to make it simple enough so that
legislators can understand it that's a
challenge legislators could understand
that everybody can understand it and I'm
hoping to have a manuscript this
December to my publisher it'll come out
sometime next year it's called
conviction machine how did this man
delay and Errol Morris the documentary
filmmaker working with me try to put
together a series of shorts illustrating
the problem that the system has both
state and federal mostly a federal
problem of the absence of what we call
mens rea requirement
and statutes we've been talking with
Harvey silverglade he's the co-author of
the shadow University co-founder a fire
author of three felonies a day and he of
the forthcoming conviction machine how
to dismantle it
Harvey thanks so much for talking with
us and the work you do my pleasure thank
you for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you